And the answer here, surprisingly,
at least I think it's very surprising
this algorithm is capable of finding any combination
of program and input that halts,
and the reason is simple; if a program halts,
then the program has a finite length,
the input has a finite length, and the number of steps in which
the program can run on the input, if it halts,
is finite, and at a certain point in time,
since this loop here is infinite,
max length will be larger than any of those 3 constraints,
and once max length has become large enough,
we will find that P terminates on the input
after a certain number of steps,
and so we will print it.
The only reason why the algorithm could not find the certain combination of
program and input is that
the program does not halt on that input.
The first one, amazingly,
means that the algorithm is indeed correct.
Of course it is totally infeasible in practice, as well,
because if you think about it,
a program is a text string;
now even for very, very, very small values of max length
the number of these text strings for the program
and of course also the number of text strings for this input here
becomes exponentially huge,
so it's a purely theoretical construct,
but it explains at least in some theoretical computer science courses,
you will hear that the Halting Problem is referred to as
recursively enumerable.
So the algorithm is totally impractical,
but it is nevertheless correct,
and that is the reason why the combination of programs and inputs
for which the program halts on the input
is called recursively enumerable,
at least in some theoretical computer science courses.
Now this one is interesting; can this algorithm be modified
to output any programs that don't halt?
And the answer here of course is no,
because this technique here clearly only works
when the program stops.
As long as the program goes on,
we can not make any statement about it.
We cannot say it's a program,
will it still continues running, if it will stop at a certain point in time,
and that is the reason why we can't modify this algorithm,
so that it finds combinations of programs that input that don't halt.
This of course also tells you again why the problem is semi decidable
because we can find those combinations here,
but we can not find those over here.